hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to one late-night deadlines
now if you remember one like night one
of the power it came out about a year
and a half ago and it was a really
interesting game where you were a guy
who was stuck in an office late at night
working overtime and there was this
ghost girl that was trying to kill you
in millions of ways now I never finished
the game myself or I never finished the
demo myself and a lot of people wanted
me to do it and I always when to go back
to it but I never got the chance but now
this full release has been put out on
Steam and it's supposed to be much
better and much more ghostly and much
more ghastly and much more scary my body
really do they darkness is shrouding the
deepest corners of my soul okay your
love delay the feelings of both sorrow
and peace of well my mind mixed signals
here what do you talked I do not know
from where it feels like I am falling
into a black and endless expanses I do
not seem to remember my name but I do
know that I am needed somewhere and I
need to get back to this place but
before my apprehensions could take over
at the empty void around me is filled by
a white light at that moment I realized
I had one last purpose in this world
that my final page has yet to be written
okay that was some lovely exposition but
does that mean that you're the same
character from before you a totally did
well oh who the hell are you oh what the
hell oh is that me that's a little
jittery
okay then Wow a camera kind of all over
the place there but I saw something move
over than the other way well alright I
can't believe this couldn't wait into
the more new objectives are shown in the
left signing sliding bar with a short
description nights will be your only
clue
so be vigilant press o to toggle your
most current objective let's get this up
any key to dismiss okay the mouse
sensitive D is really high so I'm fairly
sure I'm gonna panic and run away and
spin in circles really quickly okay so
I'm an employee late at night trying to
get something done for some project I
don't know who was giving all the
narrative but I'm assuming that he was
someone relatively important I see green
lights here does that mean good go or no
go okay I'm going in the right place I
think at least maybe I'm not maybe I am
god this mouse is obscenely sensitive
hey I remember that that's from the
first game web comm I remember that holy
hell I remember that balloon it scared
the crap out of me everyone who watched
before knows I'm dying huh
who is gonna be a bother oh they need to
fix that animation a little bit need a
different key card for this door what do
you mean I need a different key card
don't I work here I got through the
first door um maybe I can use this one
on this door I need a different key card
first oh okay I got it I can get in here
but I can't go all the way down okay
this is really wonky because this isn't
a demo anymore this is a full game on
Steam it costs money
I believe it was like 15 bucks and
there's a lot of like weird errors to it
for it being a full release game but
either way like I'm gonna play the game
to the end and then give my judgment at
the end of it but I'm just gonna like
wait a minute wait what you went away
okay so I can call the elevator if I
want to go up and down if I don't want
it wow that's my running cycle alright
then yeah I missed my target but only a
little bit that's okay I can forgive
myself all right another one Jesus
god damn how many key card things do I
need to go through almost sound at that
time you were you were kind of right on
target but not really sometimes you just
need to fax stuff press any key to
what what do you mean sometimes I just
need to fax stuff that doesn't make any
sense I need the facts up for facts the
document on your desk to client okay
is this my desk which one's my desk how
am I supposed to know which one's mine
Oh am I in here
maybe also who's the client okay this
looks important once you picked up an
item press space to end pickup mode most
items are collectibles but some are for
display like newspapers okay alright
then so I should just be able to inject
this in here the project what what
happened
oh is this the fax machine wait no what
ah okay I'm guessing those were just the
printers where's the fax machine it said
Oh to toggle objectives fax a document
on your desk to the client that seems
like really important work I'm so eager
to do that is this a fax machine there
we go almost had it
you were almost up don't know what the
hell happened there what's going on with
this game alright done was that all I
needed to do I could have gone I could
have done that from home all right
that's my objective now I don't have one
well alright then this is my desk I
remember before there were like commands
you could put into the computers hey you
want to head out and grab a beer after
work me and Jon was thinking of trying
out that new place is just open up down
in Claybrook court just a heads up but I
know you're busy though client is
demanding a new version the apt to be
down low uploaded for testing this
Monday they want a new status report
faxed immediately I know you've been
working late hours the last couple weeks
but is it vital that this land in this
project because we've got a lot of
potential future products going with
this client in the near future
WTF last night I was what the [ __ ] is
that attachment rather than it office a
new camera app when working on snapped
some random pics mmm what the hell is
that
that X my Creepo factor that's the first
decent thing I've seen I was wondering
if it was gonna pop up behind me or look
at a puppy
alright cuz I can forgive some of the
technical limitations of the story side
of it is so long it's like the
environment and the scares are there
which I guess could be a good thing but
also what the hell was that
okay why the hell was that
and what the hell is any of this why am
I here late at night why why okay was
that why the music kick up
oh I didn't call that elevator
what are you doing called that elevator
like ages ago went up to number four
that was going on in this game you're
starting to feel drowsy good maybe it's
cuz I'm working late at night do I need
some coffee I mean I don't have another
objective I'm just assuming you know
what I'm supposed to do here that took a
long time to get to the fourth floor
well this looks dreary uh-huh oh yeah
okay let's see if I can actually get
this one
oh so close guard finish the door okay
so I need to find a different key card
before I'm actually able to do anything
the only office in I've been able to
actually get into was mine oh all right
then just decide to look at my crotch
for a little bit you know how important
these crunch status checks are for a guy
like this guy okay I'll walk through a
later door I don't know what that means
I don't know which one top or bottom
I need a different key card for this
door god damn it I could get in that
office but now I gotta keep moving
forward that's the only thing that I can
do so I could God another time for a
crotch status update now going this way
I wish you would tell me I need to do
man's door it would be really nice just
for like a comfort of living or whatever
the words called or the phrases called
like just tell me what door goes to what
before I get there you know what I mean
like just a little bit it's a little bit
of warning God stop looking at your
crotch man it's not important can I get
in the bathroom I really go out stark in
there
all right what the hell is has happened
there why's it so dark where's a damn
what the hell does happened there what
the hell just happened there
janitor's closet is locked this place is
open what's over here huh
don't mind me just working late going
into the basement for no damn reason
well seriously there's no damn reason I
have a flashlight or something all right
then I don't think I'm supposed to be
here hello
did that light just turn on it totally
did it's not something where I just
rounded the corner and I only saw though
yeah excuse me
ghosts boxes you just decide alone in a
little bear
I think the game's more spooky than the
actual ghosts are yeah there's a coffee
pot I think I remember there might have
been like coffee upstairs get some
coffee from the coffee machine outside
outside outside
I can't run I'm going very slow okay so
I did not know I assumed that was my
objective but I didn't know for sure if
that actually was what is this place
anyway
I can't run at all I am permanently
walking now just because so I got to get
the coffee machine outside like outside
outsider or you just mean like outside
the office outside why am I so slow
I mean suddenly I'm really slow and the
music just stopped what is going on I'm
so slow I don't know what happened I
don't know
Oh God I could not move slower than what
I'm doing right now if I have to run
away from a ghost I am dead
I'm a million ways dead I'm gonna take
the elevator just oh boy I'm winded as
all hell I'm hoping this is just because
my character is drowsy and he needs to
get some coffee in them cuz if not
there's got to be a barrier for let's
play together goodness why did I ever
leave why did I go down to the basement
why did I spend all my own money energy
running does that even mean smart at
four o'clock lar a chip-in venir
alrighty then whatever that means
oh good this door is already open for
some reason the other one closed itself
but this one is hoping is that the
coffee machine hello don't mind me I'm
just gonna stand up on that roof
god damnit are you kidding me oh no I
thought this was it looks like a copy
machine I really gotta go outside do I
damn it god oh man oh I wanna like this
game I don't want to say bad things
about it right away but god damn I wish
I could just move a little bit move a
little bit this is a little bit come on
the other face skip to my Lou skip to my
Lou da dippity-doo gibberish ooh Baba
Baba do
your ass good get your ass going fine
I'm taking the elevator screw this
another elevators probably sorry at this
point calling it and getting it down
there
okay stairs it is then dong why what
happened
in a way I'm like so curious as to
what's going on that I'm compelled to
keep playing even though I'm getting a
little bit frustrated with everything
Oh at least I can check my crotch God ah
I'm the most douchey Walker in the world
there's no strut that's just more
douchey than this right now
whatever what rush me I'm working late
and Moroccan hand blocking dachshund
snackin Dakin where's the coffee
where's the coffee where's the coffee
my president button wrong I move just
the same speed when I crawl I wanna get
into the game okay
I'm saying I'm done I'm done freaking
out I apologize for my transgressions
but my god I just want to play the game
[Music]
where's the coffee
goddamn it already over that I don't
need to touch the wall any coffee this
is what happens when I don't have my
coffee I just get a little angry Carly
okay okay you're not gonna give me a cup
here ah yeah
yeah okay all right I am lost and I feel
like I might have done something wrong
God it says get some coffee from the
coffee machine outside outside is a very
vague term I've tried to go to multiple
places that would have been construed as
outside boy is off to a great start
okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
end it here before I lose my mind I'm
out pick it up in the next episode when
I can actually progress how about that
that's what's gonna happen
so either way thank you all so much for
watching maybe it was over like here but
this is a studio I didn't do but I
couldn't open these could I I couldn't
open the doors to my own office
maybe else I need a different office to
be the way I'm gonna check out other
options that I have and then get back to
you in the next episode so thank you all
so much for watching click the end of
days or more videos I've done check out
the original one late night it got off
to a better start in this one but it's
I'm holding out hope this is gonna be
good at the end of it it's gonna be
scary go to me I'm back well thank you
all so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next episode
so in this lake house in upstate New
York
[Music]